régime d'assurance emploi actuel ne
donne le maximum de 26 semaines de congé
avant de retourner travailler est-ce que
vous ne tourne à raison dire que la
durée des prestations et de 26 semaines
en ce moment
[Musique]
non elle est plutôt de 15 semaines mais
elle devrait passer à 26 semaines à l'it
et 2022 les prestations de maladie
l'assurance emploi d'endroits
l'équivalent de 55 % de votre salaire
pour un maximum de 595 $ par semaine ça
fait plusieurs années qu'on parle de les
allonger les loyers les papilles toutes
les factures ne sont pas payés je crains
les dettes plus que la maladie
c'est l'histoire de houda el kerfi mère
monoparentale atteintes du cancer du
sein qui a mis le sujet à l'avant plan
de l'actualité en 2016 sans assurance
privée elle est juste se tourner vers
l'assurance emploi cette année là le
gouvernement libéral a promis de aussi
le nombre de semaines de prestations et
qu'un semaine l'assurance maladie ont
été épuisés justin trudeau s'est engagé
sur nos ongles faut le faire il faut le
faire rapidement pour pour des gens
comme madame mais les libéraux ont
terminé leur premier mandat sans remplir
cette promesse
pendant la campagne électorale de 2019
ils se sont engagés formellement à faire
passer à 26 le nombre de semaines de
prestations pour les travailleurs
gravement malades dans leur dernier
budget ils ont mis côté 3 milliards de
dollars sur cinq ans pour y parvenir
c'est un changement qui toucherait près
de 170 1000 canadiens par année c'était
dans la loi de mise en oeuvre du budget
et ça prend encore un décret pour
résister à 26 semaines yves françois
blanchet tu as raison pour que la durée
des prestations grimpe à 26 semaines
l'an prochain il faut décrire du conseil
des ministres et il n'a pas été signé
avant le déclenchement des élections le
bloc québécois et le npd propose que la
durée des indemnités pour les
travailleurs gravement malade passe à 50
semaines et les conservateurs à 52
semaines